GPT 5.4 is here. Open eye literally just
dropped this today and we're going to be
testing it out live so you don't have to
figure it out yourself. This isn't a
small update. We're talking about a
brand new model that outperforms the
average office worker 83% of the time.
Can now control your computer. It plugs
directly into Excel and Google Sheets.
It uses nearly half the tokens, which
means it's faster and cheaper. There's
also um a new version called GPT 5.4
Thinking. basically a supercharge mode
where it slows down and goes deep on the
hardest problems. And for the first time
ever, it supports a 1 million token
context window. That means it can read
an entire book, an entire code base, an
entire business, and actually remember
all of it. I'm going to walk you through
everything that's new, what actually
matters, what's just hype, and whether
it's worth switching from whatever
you're using right now. If you use AI
for literally anything, work, research,
building stuff, you need to see it.
Let's get into this and we're going to
get started. So, you can see the
announcement right here. GPT 5.4
Thinking and GPT 5.4 Pro rolling out in
chat GPT 5.4 is now available in the API
and the codecs and GPT 5.4 brings uh
advances in reasoning, coding, and
agentic workflows into one Frontier
model. You can see the benchmarks right
here. I don't know if anyone cares about
benchmarks at this point to be honest.
But if you want to get started with
using this, you can go over to chat GBT
and if you've got it and it's already
rolled out to you, then you just select
5.4 in the top, right? So you got pro
and you got thinking. Thinking is like,
you know, better for longer answers. Pro
is like research grade intelligence. The
only issues with pro is like usually it
takes a long time to respond. So just
something to be aware of right there.
Now, if we have a look on OpenAI's
website, we'll take a look and we'll see
what announcement they've made on this.
Here we go. So, GPT 5.4.
It literally it just dropped a few hours
ago. Um, so it's supposed to be their
most efficient and capable Frontier
model. Honestly, like a lot of the
models in the 5 series have not been
that good. So, it'll be interesting to
see how this performs. Finally, GPT4 5.4
4 is the most efficient token
reasoning model
benchmarks
here. Good for knowledge work. Let's
just try out see how it performs. All
right. So, we're going to go inside here
and I'm going to switch. You can
actually change the thinking effort as
well for pro. So, you can change between
standard and extended. I'm going to
switch over to the thinking mode because
pro will take absolutely ages. I'm going
to try and build this. Now, let's just
check if we can get canvas on this as
well. canvas will allow us to preview
what we build, which you can, which is
great. So, I'm going to start off by
trying to build a hyper dopamine pong
game, and we'll see how that performs.
It's pretty fast when it comes out,
actually. Not too bad when it comes to
getting the answers quickly. What we can
actually do is
we can go over to Claude Sonet 4.6. And,
you know, we'll change it to Opus, uh,
Claude Opus 4.6, and we'll run exactly
the same prompt. and just see which one
gives us the best output, how they
perform side by side and that sort of
thing. So, we've got Chat GPT over here
and we have Claude over here and they're
both running the same prompt. We'll see
how they perform. Damovicious says they
just can't keep up with Anthropic. I
would agree. Like, I mean, Anthropic is
just it's too good, isn't it? Actually,
I think they hit number one in the um
app store charts recently. Anthropic,
they went from like 131 in January to
number one in February. So they're
absolutely crushing it. I don't know if
anyone saw the news, but actually 1.5
million people quit chat in the space of
like 48 hours recently. Pretty crazy
stuff.
Now the other thing to note here as well
is like it does pretty well on computer
use too. So you can see an example here
like it's operating someone's emails and
then over here it's working on a bulk
data entry as well. So it can like fill
out forms and that sort of thing. So I
think one of the improvements is that
it's designed for computer use, right?
It's designed to be much better at
computer use as well. Let's see what
we're up to. All right, I think we've
got the outputs here. Yep. So, we've got
the finished version of this pong game
from ChachiPT. Claude is still building
out, so we'll come back to that in a
minute. Let's have a look and see how
this performs. So, it's winning on speed
when it comes to cord, but let's see if
it's winning on outputs. So, this is the
game itself that's been built. It's not
bad. It's pretty cool. For some reason,
I'm not playing the computer. It's just
like me versus me, which is kind of
annoying. Uh, but it did beat Claude on
speed. Let's see how Claw performs in
terms of the actual game. I would
actually say in some ways, you know, I
think the game that Chat GPT created was
a bit more interesting. Let's just go
back to Chat GPT here. Look at this one.
This is way more fun. No. So, I mean, in
terms of the output side by side, I
would say that GPT 5.4 created a better
game. Not that I'm recommending
switching or anything like that, but
it's it creates something pretty nice.
It's done a decent job there for sure.
Oh, this is interesting as well. The
zoom says, "I'm impressed with GPD 514
in computer use. Absolutely fast and
precise." Nice. Yeah, it's done it's
done a pretty good job there. It's
created nice for sure. Let's try
something else now. So, what I'm going
to do is I'm going to take the
information from my website here and
we'll, you know, this is an actual use
case. So, we're going to say right take
the information from my AR profit
boarding website
and create a new redesign. Let's see how
it performs when it comes to creating a
new website
for my AI profitable community. So, it's
beginning to do that right here. Is this
AI or the real person? This is a real
person. So I've just plugged the copy
right in from my website plus this
prompt on redesigning the air profitable
website and then it's going to start
creating a new version here and we'll
see if it's better than the original.
The original was actually built directly
with claude. So be interested to see
okay which one outperforms each other.
Let's have a look here too for computer
use. How are people using that? Is that
just through I assume that's through the
agent unless you've got your own sort of
like browser extension like nano browser
for using your computer. I assume people
using chat GBT operator to test out.
Claude is rude to me. Well, that's no
good, is it? All right, so we got agent
over here. We could test this out and
see how the computer use goes. Um, so
I'm going to say, okay, great list on
Google Maps of the best Copenhagen
bakeries because who isn't looking for
bakeries in Copenhagen right now? And
we'll test it out and see how that
performs in terms of speed on the
operator as well. I guess this will be
pretty good inside
Chat GPT atlas as well. But yeah, it's
pretty fast. Look at that. It's a lot
faster than it used to be, for sure. So
this is the agent being tested inside
Chat GPT operator. We've now got the
website back as well. So, let's see how
that performs. So, it's beginning to
create the environment for that. I don't
know why Chat Chubity always does this,
but when it's designing websites, it
always seems to have like this bit over
here. Just doesn't look good on web
design. Should be like cleaner. Like
this should be the main sort of banner
and then that should be underneath. Like
if you scroll down the page overall,
it's not bad, but that doesn't seem like
a huge step up from the designs I've
created with codeex before. Certainly
Sonet beats it in terms of the design
and the UI that it would normally
create. So I would say Claude is winning
in that respect. The other thing I'm not
100% sure of is if we're using operator.
Let me just double check here. Yes. So
if you're using operator, it doesn't say
that it's implemented inside. So there's
no confirmation that GPT 5.4 is inside
uh operator. Chatg. That's what I'm
wondering. Although it does seem to have
become a lot faster in general. But
overall, it's one of those where I don't
think I would switch anytime soon, but
it seems pretty decent, right? It seems
like a decent start. I just think that
Claude is so far ahead at this point,
like it's almost impossible to to catch
up. So, just to recap on GT 5.4,
literally just came out. It's built for
work. So, it's designed to be less
errorprone, more efficient, and better
at workplace tasks like drafting
documents. and we can create files in
fewer tries and it outperformed office
workers 83% of the time which is pretty
crazy. It uses fewer tokens and it's
faster so it's faster and cheaper and
then also it can control your computer.
On top of that it can work inside Excel
and Google Sheets as well. And there's
two versions that I can see of it which
is GPT 5.4 thinking which is you know
the version um that we've been using for
creating the websites today but then
you've also got GT 5.4 4 Pro, which is
probably super powerful and amazing for
research, but it just takes too long to
test on um videos like this. And that's
basically it. So, if you want to get all
the video notes from today and all my
best trainings and everything else, you
can get that inside the AI profit
boardroom link in the comments
description or just go to the AI
profitable.com. This is my community
focused on helping you save time and
scale with AI automation. Inside the
community, I have 2,600 members, which
means that you can get help, you can get
support, you can share your wins, etc.
And there's always people online, which
is awesome. Inside the post here, you
can see that we have a daily
accountability group. So, if you
struggle with information overload or
overwhelm, you can post your goals, stay
accountable, and stay laser focused.
With this, you can also see what other
people working on, which is pretty cool.
And then also, each week I condense my
60 hours of research into a quick weekly
update that tells you what's good and
what you can ignore so that you can save
time um and just focus on the good
stuff. In addition, we have four weekly
video coaching calls, which means you
can jump on live coaching calls, get
help and support real time. You can meet
people in your local area. So, you can
just zoom into your local area and find
people um locally. We actually have at
this point
134 pages of testimonials of people
winning from the school groups and the
trainings that we do. So, there's a lot
of people getting awesome results, which
is great to see. And then also inside
the classroom here, you'll get our best
training. So, for example, you can go
from beginner to expert with AI
automation and learn how to build your
first AI agent in under 5 minutes.
Additionally, you'll get all my best
trainings, for example, for how to
automate X, newsletters, shorts,
Instagram AI avatar videos, etc. And
then additionally, you can get my daily
updates here, which means that every
single day where I did new guides,
training you on new things, I look at
all the updates that came out and I give
you the most relevant ones and then I
share them with step-by-step guides and
video tutorials inside the AI profit
board. So, it's always active and is
always coming out with new trainings
that are updated. Additionally, you can
learn how to get more clients with the
agency course. You can watch back the
coaching course if you don't make them
live. You can learn how to rank number
one with AI SEO inside Google and AI
search engines. And then also you can
learn how to grow a YouTube channel
based on what's working for me with AI
directly inside the classroom as well.